Vi brukar säga samma sak.
Vi är...
Vi ska ha julbord idag, då är det ju vi.
Det är ju mest...
Vi är ju bara folk från landet.
Då blir det ju en viss...
Det kan bli bra.
Det kan bli hyggligt.
Det kör vi på.
Det får det bli.
Klart.
Då går vi vidare.
Då säger vi välkommen till podden Kim.
Hejsan, tack så mycket.
Ja, tack så mycket.
Du får rätta mig om jag har fel här, men om jag skulle beskriva dig för poddlyssnare som inte vet vem du är så är du spindeln i nätet bakom hela Strongman Sverige.
Kommer någon bli för närmad om jag säger så?
Det vet jag inte, men det är ju smittrande när du säger det, absolut.
Men jag känner ju ett stort engagemang för sporten, både på amatör-
och elitsidan.
Så det är smittrande att du beskriver mig på det viset.
Men jag vet inte om jag kan hålla med riktigt, men just nu så är jag nog ganska aktuell i alla fall.
Hur många tävlingar tror du att du har arrangerat de senaste tio åren?
Jag gjorde min första tävling 2017 och sen har det ju rullat på lite, men jag skulle nog tro att det är nog över 100 i alla fall.
I år så är vi uppe i kraftkamp på 30 tävlingar och vi har varit med på 31 tävlingar.
Då hjälpte vi till på Greppes.
Det var inte våran tävling eller så, men vi var ju ändå medverkade där på sätt och vis.
Så 100 är ju ingen överdrift, det tror jag inte.
Nej det tror inte jag eller det känns som att det är betydligt fler.
Det är helt okej att vara ödmjuk i vanliga livet, men jag känner att när man är i den här podden då får man skryta lite om sig själv.
Så här är det bara att ta ut svängarna.
Om någon inte vill lyssna får de bara dra härifrån.
Ja men det låter bra.
Kan du inte berätta lite hur du hamnade i Strongman?
Egentligen, för att börja historien så träffade jag Anders Elfet, han är en kompis till mig på en ordningsvaktutbildning i Jönköping.
Det måste ha varit 2004 eller 2005.
Han höll på med Strongman på amatörnivå då.
Han hade tävlat lite i minus 105 och lite sådana tävlingar också.
Lite bonde tävlingar och sånt.
Så vi lärde känna varandra.
Vi tyckte om varandra där vi då lärde känna varandra och han höll på med det och tävlade som sagt.
Jag har aldrig varit någon tävlingsmänniska på det viset och egentligen inte varit intresserad av det.
Men sen startade han något, jag tror det hette smipodd eller någonting sånt.
Så startade han en firma och började sälja lite gymutrustning.
Då hade han som sidor på att tillverka enklare strongmanutrustning.
Så då köpte jag det av honom, vad kan det ha varit, 2009 kanske.
Jag började träna lite på det.
Sedan slet jag av biceps 2010.
Det känns som en klassisk skada.
En vecka utan att ha tävlat, ett skit också.
Jag hade kollat missommafton, nykte, vill jag bara tillägga, hade kollat på YouTube hur man skulle göra när man vältade däck.
Jag tyckte inte jag hade bra teknik, så kom en kompis förbi och hade sett att jag hade traktordäck hemma och ville att jag skulle välta och då small biceps.
Så det var att sitta på akuten på midsommarafton.
Men sen efter lite chart så här under några år så lyckades Anders övertala mig att tävla för första gången 2014 i Asnes, utan Venezsjö.
Så där var ju egentligen min debut.
Jag kom dit, jag är inte så liten men jag tyckte alla andra var jättestora och hade sleeves och bälten och allting och jag kom dit i shorts och t-shirt.
Aldrig använt magnesium eller någonting sådant.
Så där gjorde jag min tävlingsdebut.
Så det är lite så jag halkade in på det, tack för att jag lärde känna Anders då.
Och senare även Rune Andersson då.
Och han är ju en legend i sammanhanget om man säger så.
Det var så det började för mig och jag trodde inte att jag var tävlingsmänniska.
Men shit när man väl står där och ska tävla då blir det liksom tunnelseende och det är rätt så härligt faktiskt.
Har man inte upplevt det innan?
Och jag hade ju som sagt inte gjort det utan fastnade för det rejält då.
Hur gick tävlingskarriären?
Ja, jag inledde med att vinna första grenen i tävlingen.
Från att folk hade varit lite avvaktande mot en och så här.
Då helt plötsligt så kunde ju folk gå och prata med en och undra hur man tränade.
Jag hade ju ingen aning om hur andra tränade, utan jag tränade på mitt vis i en fabrik helt ensam.
Så det gick ju bra i första grenen, andra grenen kom jag tvåa.
Sen är det där jävulsmomentet pressa över huvudet.
Det hade jag faktiskt varit nere på kvällen innan.
När jag anmälde mig och provat om jag skulle klara en repetition över huvudet.
Det gjorde jag på kvällen innan, men på tävlingen så boomade jag.
Sen var det inte jag något hot i tävlingen över huvudet längre.
Det var kronan Serkel efter tror jag också.
Det gick helt åt helvete, jag tog den helt fel.
Sen sista var däckvält.
Trots att jag släpp av bicep några år innan så är det en favoritövning för mig.
Den kom jag två eller trea i också.
Jag landade någonstans i mitten.
Så jag är en medelmotta.
Jag har inte haft någon ambition eller så.
Men det är jävligt kul att tävla.
Man har ju alltid folk i statsfältet att mäta sig med, oavsett om man är i toppen eller om man är i botten.
Man får kolla ut någon som man retar sig lite på så får man försöka göra allt för att slå den personen.
Jag förstår, jag förstår precis.
Men du nämnde att du kände dig lite liten i sammanhanget.
Vi kan ju nämna att du är en stor person.
Jag har ju träffat dig live några gånger och jag ser ut som din lilla förkynta lillebror som aldrig fick tillväxthormoner som barn.
Jag vet inte hur man ska säga men man kände sig ganska...
Det var en del stora killar, jag var absolut inte minst men sen kände man sig som lite bottkommet för alla hade, du vet, neoprenbälte, hårtbälte över det, sleeves på armarna och jag ägde inga sådana saker.
Utan jag kom dit i shorts och t-shirt och jag kände mig såhär, fan, fan har jag gett mig in på.
Och som sagt, sedan var folk lite såhär, och det är väl inte för att folk är otrevliga för det är en jäkligt härlig community, strongman, men alla är lite på sin vakt innan en tävling och alla är givetvis nervösa.
Jag var inte den enda som var skitnervös, utan det var väl lite det, men så lossnade det lite för folk efter mig.
Jag upplevde att det var några killar som var jäkligt bitig tyckte jag, men han slog jag ju faktiskt.
Storleken är ju inte allt, säger de.
Men är strongmen bara för stora människor?
Nej, absolut inte.
Det beror ju på lite hur tävlingarna ser ut.
Om du tar de tävlingarna som jag nämnde innan, Rune Andersson i Kusrud håller i.
Vi kan ju nämna förr så att folk vet om att vi på Gymkompaniiet hade lager ut oss Rune i tio år, så honom känner vi ju väl.
Ja, precis.
Du känner ju Rune väldigt väl.
Ja, absolut.
Och hans tävlingar, där kan man ju säga att det är mycket max-antal repetitioner, max distans och där har du ju kanske inte jättestor nytta av att vara stor och bitig.
Utan där kan du vara lite mindre och ändå göra jäkligt bra ifrån dig för att du kanske syresätter helt annorlunda och så där.
Sen finns det de som inte gillar den typen av tävlingar men jag tycker ju liksom att en strongman-tävling ska ha en bra mix av både statiskt tunga övningar och lite pannben och uthållighet.
Så att man måste vara stor, det är liksom, det håller jag nog inte riktigt med om.
Det är därför det finns olika viktklasser också.
Som i våra amatör-tävlingar, som i jaskocen till exempel, där har vi lätta klassen, tunga klassen och elitklassen.
Och du kan ju vara stor och tung, men inte så jättestark och tävla i den lätta klassen.
Och så kan du vara en liten kille och tävla i elitklassen och liksom sopa mattan med de som är större.
Så där har vi inga viktklasser.
Så nej, men sen när man kommer till eliten och när det handlar om liksom tungvikt och så, då har ju givetvis kroppsvikt en stor fördel.
Speciellt när det är statiskt och du kanske ska dra saker och så.
Det är klart att det är skillnad, men på amatörsidan så tror jag inte det har så stor betydelse egentligen.
Vad väger en, vad ska vi kalla det då, en elit-elit-strongman i snitt?
Ja, det finns ju givetvis undantag, men jag tror faktiskt de flesta ligger runt 145-150 kg kanske.
Det finns de som ligger kanske närmare 170 kg och så finns det ju de som kanske ligger runt 125-130 kg som Anton Vasse och Gustav Stonegård till exempel, men de är väldigt konkurrenskraftiga i alla fall.
Så det finns ett stort span, men jag skulle nog säga att de flesta ligger runt 145-150 kg på elitnivå då om man säger.
Vad är din bakgrund innan strongman?
Tränar du någonting då?
Ja, sen jag var 15-16 så gjorde man den här vanliga gymträningen om man säger.
Bodybuilding, pumpa.
Bicepsbröst.
Och det gjorde jag ju fram.
Ja, precis.
Jag körde det klassiska upplägget.
Tränar två dagar, vilar igen och så rullade det så.
Oavsett om det var jul, nyår eller midsommar.
Man var det träningsdag, då fanns man tränade.
Den karaktären är ju helt borta nu.
Nu är man glad om man får till något träningspass då och då.
Men det var min bakgrund.
Och som sagt, sen träffade jag Anders Rätta, sagt under ordningsvaktutbildningen där.
Om det var 2004-2005.
Och senare köpte jag lite utrustning av honom.
Och när jag började träna den typen av träning, då blev den här gymträningen ganska tråkig.
Men jag hade nog en ganska bra grundträning om man säger.
Just genom att ha nöt på och man hade kört liksom.
Men det var inte så att man körde marklyft något regelvundet eller pressa över huvudet eller sådär.
Men man hade nog ändå en viss grundstyrka som en fördel av det då.
Men som sagt när jag väl började träna på strongman eller träna de typen av grenarna, då fastnade jag för det rätt så rejält.
Du kan mäta det i tid, du kan mäta det i vikt.
Då blev det helt plötsligt tråkigt att stå och köra bicepskörl i en maskin.
Så där måste jag säga, det var nog så.
Jag fastnade för det.
Styrketräning är min bakgrund.
Jag är helt värdelös på fotboll.
Jag gillar konceptet fotboll.
Jag tränade när jag var yngre.
Men helt värdelös, bollsinn och inte liksom...
Jag tyckte det var kul att träna, men jag gillade inte matcher och sådana saker.
Jag känner att, säga att jag kommer intervjua jag vet inte hur många människor i den här podden genom tiderna här, men...
Det känns som att ingen kommer vara bra på bollsport.
För då hänger man inte i styrkevärlden.
Alltså det finns ju alltid de där jävlarna som är typ bra på precis allting de tar sig för.
De kan börja lyfta stort eller spela gitarr.
De är så målmedvetna att lösa det.
Men jag håller nog med.
Det kanske inte är majoriteten som har bollsinnen liksom eller kanske lagidrottare på det viset.
Ja.
Du började sträna strongman och sen tävlar du lite.
Hur kommer det sig att du börjar anordna tävlingar?
Ja, det var 2016 så var jag med och hjälpte till på en tävling i Växjö.
Det var en kille som skulle arrangera tävlingen.
Han hade ingen direkt erfarenhet av det.
Han hade vunnit en tävling själv.
Sen kände han att nu var han mogen att arrangera en tävling.
Som sagt, jag var med som funktionär för övrigt enda funktionären.
Så jag bade tillbaka alla grejer.
Jag lyfte upp stena som de inte skulle hämta från marken utan från ett bord.
Lyfte upp när de hade tappat dem i max distanser.
Jag var med och hjälpte till där.
Jag tyckte inte att han gjorde det så himla bra.
När jag frågade han dagen innan tävling om han hade ordnat några funktionärer, så var han helt förvånad.
Han förstod inte riktigt vad jag menade.
Han hade ju dig.
Han hade nog...
Vad sa du?
Han hade ju dig.
Ja, precis.
En funktionär.
Han hade nog missat ganska mycket i det här och liksom typ...
Det gick ju inte så bra.
Han fick dessutom liksom som lite efterspel av det så stämde inte resultaten för folk.
Det var ganska rörigt och jag stod där lite mitt emellan honom och fick ta ganska mycket av det som folk hörde av sig om och kan du hjälpa han med det här och det här.
Så det blev jag så här liksom att fan ska det vara så jävla svårt, det kan det ju inte vara liksom.
Och jag tror detta var i maj 2016 eller någonting sånt där.
Eller om det var på hösten, jag blir lite osäker nu.
Men det var i alla fall där jag träffade det som senare blev min kollega Kalle.
För han var och tävlade på den tävlingen och om jag minns rätt så vann han sin klass som man säger.
Men det var nog där det såddes ett frö, att fan det här blev inte bra.
Lägger man bara lite energi på att planera och tänka igenom det innan, så kan man ju bygga bort mycket av de här jävla felen som blev där.
Om man är metodisk och konsekvent och så här något inte hamnar.
Så där föddes nog tanken om att anordna en tävling för första gången om man säger.
Och vilken var din första tävling sen?
Det blev Slaget om Småland.
Och det var, som sagt, beroende på när den här tävlingen i Växjö var, så blev det ungefär ett halvår, ett år efter.
Det var i juli 2017.
Som jag anordnade den.
Och där har det blivit lite tävlingar de sista åren.
Men som sagt 2017 var det första gången vi körde den.
Och då tog jag kontakt med en lokal idrottsförening i Åsida som är grannsamhället där jag bor då.
De har en festlighet som kallas Olsmässan varje år.
Hela Åsida är på den festen och de är väldigt såhär.
När det görs någonting i det samhället, de är fantastiska på, då kommer folk liksom.
Och jag visste sedan innan att fredagarna, där hade de egentligen ingenting, det var då Olsmässan startade.
Så då hade de inget event eller så, så då kontaktade jag OEF som föreningen heter och frågade om de skulle vara intresserade av att ha, ja, vara värd för en slångman-tävling.
Då har man ju liksom ett uppbyggt område, det finns ljus, ljud, barer, restaurang och öltält och typ sådana saker.
Och det var de intresserade av och då liksom började jag jobba med det.
Ja, det måste ha varit i januari, februari, vi började ragga runt sponsorer och sådär.
Och då körde vi med upplägget rensponsorer då och sen så att det var prispengar till topp tre i varje gren, plus att vi skänkte en viss del av varje rensponsor, sponsorpengar till barnkanserfonden då.
Så det blev upplägget och vi hade fem grenar inom tävlingen och sen en sjätte, ja, en gren utom tävlan då där jag tror renseraren vann typ 3 000 kronor.
Så det var ganska fina prispengar och det blev en ganska fin inramning på tävlingen med.
Det blev succé liksom.
Folket i Åseda tog verkligen tävlingen till sitt hjärta och liksom när man var ut och gick sen i samhället så stannade folk bilen och berättade om hur kul det var.
Så jag la ribban väldigt högt på den tävlingen och jag tycker att det blev jättelyckat.
Det tyckte de som var med och de som tittade med.
Men sen var jag med och tävlade själv också och hjälpte till lite att rådda och så i tävlingen.
Sedan hade jag blivit pappa precis två veckor innan tävlingen också.
Det var ganska hektisk tid där precis innan.
Men det var väldigt kul och fan jag är jävligt glad att jag gjorde det.
Där tävlade jag också, det var för första gången, förmodligen sista jag tävlade tillsammans med Kalle.
Och Kalle vann den tävlingen efter den sista grenen.
De låg lika efter fem renar så den sjätte och sista grenen som var utom tävlan fick bli avgörande för vem som vann tävlingen.
Jag har nog aldrig sett en människa så trött som Kalle var efter den tävlingen.
Han typ hade legat och sovit i baksätet i bilen hem.
Så han sambo fick köra hem honom så.
Men det var den första tävlingen och det var ett fint minne var det.
Jag kan tänka mig att Josefin Kalles sambo är ganska besviken över att den där tävlingen blev bra.
Det var där jag och Kalle lärde känna varandra.
Så det var...
Sen tog era helger och era semestrar slut.
Ja, Kalle har väl inga helger och lediga så ändå.
Han är ju ICA-handlare så han har inte mycket fritid som man har.
Det ledde sen till att vi 2018 så drog igång den här amatör-serien, Jasko-serien.
Då tyckte jag att det inte bara kan vara tävlingar.
Sommaren funkar inte utan vi måste kunna hålla igång och tävla och få rutin på det och få in nya i spotten även på lågsäsong så då startade Jasko-serien.
Men var det du då eller hade du och Kalle redan då blivit ett team?
Nej det var jag som startade den och jag hade den på där jag hade min gymutrustning så startade jag den på lagret där och den kan man säga, det blev som en motpol tillslaget av Småland.
Det skulle istället vara helt avskalat, liksom där ingen domare, inga funktionärer utan de som var med och tävlade vi var varandras funktionärer.
Det skulle inte vara så jävla krångligt att göra en ursäkta att jag svär, en tävling utan det var liksom raka motsatsen, alltså tävla för tävlandet skulle och för att det var roligt eller så.
Så där var det liksom där att då var jag ju liksom tidtagare och domare och lite funktionär och sen så när de hade gått jag vet, jag tror vid första tävlingen vi hade Farmers Walk i den tunga klassen med 120 och 140 kilo per hand så fick man liksom gå och bära tillbaka viss utrustning emellan och sen så högsflux var det min tur och då fick någon annan ta klockan på med bältet och så körde man sitt race och sen så var det tillbaka igen liksom.
Men det har ju spårat nu, Jaskås i en sen dess, det har ju höjt sig många nivåer men det var så vi började liksom att det var en väldigt avskalad tävling.
Den fokus var på att ha bra tävlingar under enkla former eller så.
Men du nämner Kalle här några gånger, kan du inte beskriva vem det är och när ni började köra ihop och vad det gav?
Ja, Kalle som sagt är ju min kollega i Kraftkamp.
Vi började faktiskt köra ihop, jag nämnde ju Jaskåsheren här och att vi tävlade mot varandra året innan i slaget av Småland.
Men Jaskåsheren 2018 hade han en deltävling i sin lada, den här klassiska ladan i Regnhult som har växt många gånger om nu i utrymme inuti.
Jag tror vi körde, jag är osäker på om vi körde en deltävling på våren och en på hösten.
Men jag tror det var så att vi körde den sista deltävlingen på hösten också.
Så Kalle har ju varit med och gjort tävlingar tillsammans med mig genom Jaskåsheren sedan dess då.
Han gjorde det även 2019.
Och 2019 så gjorde jag ett försök och låta andra vara med och arrangera tävlingarna.
Kalle löste det medan de andra kände jag att då kunde jag lika gärna göra det själv.
Det var så mycket som man ville ha kontroll på.
Men Kalle kunde man släppa det till om man visste att när man kom dit så var det mest fixat eller så.
Så det följde sig nog ganska naturligt att det blev han jag frågade när jag väl kände att jag inte hade med det själv.
Och Kalle är en jävligt arbetsam människa.
Som jag nämnde så är han Ikehandlare och med det så har han inte speciellt mycket fritid eller så.
Och han är inte rädd för jag vet inte hur många gånger när vi har förberett tävlingar i jaskålscén när jag har varit hos han i Regnhult där vi kanske har fått en timme sömn.
I bästa fall innan tävlingen har dragit igång liksom.
Så han är väldigt arbetsam och pålitlig.
Och sen har han gjort ett jättebra jobb med att få igång vår livestream.
Det var vi ganska tidiga med och det har ju spårat ut.
Så jag tror att vi har två eller tre sådana PTZ-kamera som han kan sitta och ratta från mixerbordet och sådana saker.
Och det gör han jäkligt bra.
Det lyfter ju våran serie många gånger om.
Vi kanske inte har jättemånga som kollar på våra tävlingar men det gör ju ändå det möjligt för de som anhöriga till dem som är och tävlar, och kunna följa tävlingarna utan att vara på plats i ladan.
Exakt, och man har ju sett en del fantastiska filmer där folk har lagt upp när de sitter hemma i soffan tio pers och kollar med någon bekant som tävlar.
Alla sitter och fikar och kikar, det är rätt häftigt.
Ja, det har gjort väldigt mycket och vi har lite det tänket båda två att vi kanske inte alltid tar den lättaste vägen när det gäller vissa saker, utan det får vara lite omständigt.
Bara det ser bra ut och att det blir bra i genomförandet med.
Så vi försöker, som ni är vår största sponsor i serien, vi försöker att ni ska exponeras, de som sponsrar serien ska synas.
Att det ska kännas som att ni inte bara ger oss pengar.
Sen så struntar vi det, utan då syns ni i livestreamen, ni syns på exponeringen bakom podier och allting sånt.
Där är Kalle jäkligt duktig på det, att hitta lösningar på det.
Så det syns bra och så det ser bra ut.
Det är en fantastisk kollega.
Sen hinner vi aldrig träffas, utan vi träffas bara när vi har tävlingar.
Jag brukar komma till han på fredagen och sen så jobbar vi någon timme och så åker vi och käkar pizza.
Sen jobbar vi en bit in på natten och så går vi och lägger oss.
Sen så upp och så kör vi tävlingar.
Lördag och söndag då.
Vi hinner inte umgås så mycket privat för vi har oss fullt upp med våra vanliga liv.
Vi är småbarnsföräldrar, båda två med.
Du vet ju själv, då har man ju inte så himla mycket tid överallt.
Men när vi träffas så har vi väldigt roligt.
Han har en speciell typ av hum och han kan få ner en.
Jag kommer ihåg ett exempel på hur Calle fungerar efter Sveriges starkaste mannfinalen 2021.
Man gick lite på moln, det kändes som en succé.
Sen frågade jag Calle att det var väl inte så märkvärdigt.
Det tycker jag är ju inne, men han är lite sådant att han är lite sådär.
Så flynade han lite.
Det är väl ändå inga som tittar på live-streamen på SSM-finalen, men det var det ju, det var ju många som geekade.
Lite svart hum och så, det är roligt.
Det är tur att inte folk hör oss när vi går ensamma på natten där och jobbar.
Vi brukar säga samma sak.
Vi är...
Ja men jag kan tänka mig det.
Vi ska ha julbord idag, då är det ju vi.
Alltså det är ju mest, ska vi säga, vi är ju bara folk från landet.
Och det kan vara väldigt befriande att man går där och så kommer det någon riktigt bräpa kommentar från ingenstans och då blir man glad.
Eller så här när det är...
Ja, jag brukar hetsa honom lite som senaste tävlingen när vi körde finalen för herrarna i vår amatörserie.
Så hetsade han lite och gick och lyfte av lätta klassens båda vikter.
Så då var han tvungen att lyfta han också.
Oj vad han ojade sig och han är ju helt slut om man får säga det själv.
Men han är ju, Kalle är ju fruktansvärt stark.
Han har ju till och med tagit sig vidare från ett SSM-kval någon gång och så där.
Så han är ju en duktig strongman också.
Även om man inte hinner träna i så stor utsträckning just nu då.
Ni har ju, det är ju tydligt när du pratar och det är tydligt hur du beskriver hela upplägget, men det drivs ju som en ganska passionerad verksamhet detta.
Den drivs ju mer på passion än på monetär ersättning.
Jo det kan man väl säga.
Skulle man sluta arbetet eller?
Vad tror du du har för timpeng?
Ja, jag får ju betala, jag får jobba där.
Vi tar ju inte ut någon lön som vi inte gör, utan båda två har ju jobb liksom så vi klarar oss eller så.
Vi har inte känt att vi behöver göra det eller så.
Det har inte riktigt varit vårt mål heller med kraftkamp.
Men någon timlön, det är ju inte...
Vi brukar skojera lite när man har, som när vi har haft SSM-finalen, att då får de flesta andra, givetvis inte våra funktionärer, men domare och spik och allting, alla får lön men vi tar inte ut någon lön själva eller så.
Men det är ju som sagt valfritt.
Det är ju inte det som driver oss och inte.
Men kan man få ut som man skulle kunna leva på det en viss procent i framtiden så hade det ju varit fantastiskt kul.
Det är svårt också, det är svårt att få den typen av lönsamhet i det.
Och sen kanske skillnaden från oss jämfört med andra arrangörer av tävlingar det är ju att vi driver kraftkamp som ett företag med och då måste man ju betala skatt och det ska...
Ja, det där har Kalle koll på med siffrorna och den biten.
Men det går ju åt mycket eller så.
Så det gör jag.
Men jag tänker ett flertal frågor baserat på det där.
Dels så...
En av anledningarna till...
Vi har ju varit med och sponsrat er länge i alla möjliga olika konstellationer.
Och det är ju just för att ni är så fruktansvärt professionella i det ni gör.
Ni är ju...
Ja, du är ju väldigt...
När du och jag har en dialog så är det ju ingenting som lämnas åt slumpen utan jag är ju mycket mer slafsig än vad du är.
Ja men det är ju kul att...
Och ni spesar ju och det syns ju alltid och jag märker ju det när ni jobbar, oavsett vilka ni jobbar med som sponsorer så syns ju dem mycket och ni ger mycket cred till alla och ni är väldigt framåt på det där.
Samtidigt så driver ni ju, som du säger, ni gör ju detta väldigt mycket baserat på passion och ni lägger er an tid och ni lägger...
Vad är det som gör att man orkar lägga den energin?
Och har ni varit nära på att känna att vi pallar inte detta längre?
Nu kan jag inte tala för kalle, känner jag, men jag tyckte ju det var jobbigt innan jag körde det själv, innan jag tog med kalle i dig och innan vi bildade kraftkamp, för då kände jag att, fan du vet, om man har en tävling och det kanske är fyrtio deltagare och alla swishar pengar till mig personligen på mitt swishkonto och jag liksom tar inte ut någon vinst för det.
Och så tänkte man så här shit om skattemyndigheten, börja titta på det här och liksom man tjänade inga pengar på det, då kände vi så här liksom, jag pratade med kalle om han skulle vilja vara med på något hörn om vi startade någonting.
Så sa vi det att, men fan då startar vi ett aktievolag liksom och det blir mycket lättare, det blir lättare för er som är sponsorer av tävlingarna om vi har ett företag och ni, liksom det blir inte en privat person att ge pengarna utan då gör vi, vi byter tjänster kan man ju säga på sätt och vis.
Så därav valde vi att starta Kraftkamp liksom och, och då känner jag ju att det har blivit lite lättare liksom att, då blir det inte liksom ens personliga ekonomi som blir ihopröat med något företag utan då kan vi hålla isär det liksom.
Men som sagt som du säger, vi lägger ju väldigt mycket tid och, och drivkraften är ju egentligen att vi ser att det utvecklas hela tiden.
Vi kan ju faktiskt höja våra startavgifter.
Vi tyckte ju liksom när vi började ta 250 kronor för en tävling att, nu får vi nog bromsa lite, men nu är vi uppe liksom på 550-600 kronor och, sett till vad man faktiskt får för de tävlingarna, så är det ju egentligen inte.
Jag har flera som tävlar i styrkelyft, som tävlar i våra tävlingar där de ska ha licenser och de ska, det kostar om du ska tävla i styrkelyft, ska du tävla i bara bänkpress och kostar det, alltså då är det kanske inte så farligt, men vi känner någonstans att vi vill inte strämma bort folk för att det ska vara för dyrt heller eller så.
Men någonstans, vi får väl ta en lektion av dig hur vi ska få ut så vi kan vara på lönsamhet.
Nej men, som sagt, som du säger, det är passionen som driver det.
Och jag vet inte hur man ska förklara det, Strongman är ju, du har ju träffat många Strongmans, det är ju en härlig Strongwoman, det är ju en härlig community liksom, det är trevliga människor som håller på med det, vanliga människor, liksom som du och jag om man säger, det är liksom inga märkvärdiga personer.
Och då vill jag lägga till att i våran serie, de deltagarna som är med i våran serie, där kan vi ju slå ut det över en hel säsong.
Du träffar inte bara dina medtävlande en gång på en tävling och kanske på sin höjd på en tävling till, utan du träffar dem fyra gånger under säsongen.
Det blir ju en helt annan gemenskap där.
Det är jäkligt fint att stå vid sidan av och se det, för att det kommer in en ny.
Till exempel, vi hade några killar nu när vi fick lite avhopp av höstens deltävlingar, kommer det in en ny.
Dels är vi i månen om att de ska känna sig välkomna och sädda och sådär.
Men sen är det ju de killarna som har tävlat i våran serie, tar ju till sig dem direkt, de läser deras namn, de kuschar, de visar, de lånar ut bälten om det behövs.
Det blir en väldigt fin gemenskap i våran serie och det tror jag är lite unikt, eftersom det blir det på amatörnivå.
Bland tjejerna och killarna i våra serie.
Det gör det värt, det låter kanske lite klyschigt, men det gör det värt.
Allt arbete liksom, och se det.
För någonstans när de tänker på strongman och strongwoman, så är det ju kraftkamp de tänker på.
Det blir ju deras inkörspott till spotten och kanske det första de kopplar samman med strongman liksom.
Så det gör det liksom.
Det är nog en stor del av passionen liksom att det blir...
Fan det är något häftigt egentligen att ha byggt upp den community som vi har i den serien liksom.
Det är svårt att förklara men det känns så liksom att...
Ja, det är härligt att se det vid sidan av lite sådär liksom.
När man står och hänger mellan grenarna, när alla pushar varandra och känner varandra liksom så.
Och vi har ju folk, jag tror det längsta, jag vet inte hur långt det är till Boden, men vi har ju en kille Daniel, han åker ju liksom 140 mil ner och tävlar i en lada i Småland på Boden och sen så åker han 140 mil hem liksom på söndagen.
Det gör han ju av en anledning liksom.
Det är ju något speciellt, det måste jag säga.
Ni har ju också en, det blir ju ganska ofta så i, jag är ju gammal kampsportare och det är lite på samma sätt.
Det finns ju inga, det finns inte folk som lever på det utan det är ofta eldsjälar som driver och även duktiga idrottare som, alltså man gör ju det efter jobbet liksom.
Men ni har ju lyckats skapa en kontinuitet i tävlingarna och det är ju ganska ovanligt i sådana här sporter, vad man ska säga, sidosporter som inte är fotboll, innebandy, hockey, kvittning kanske.
Då är det ju ofta någon som anordnar en tävling för att den är engagerad och sen slutar den efter två år och så får någon annan.
Men ni har ju, som du nämner, ni har ju Slaget om Småland, ni har ju Gärdsgårdsserien som ju, jag vet inte hur många tävlingar det är per år som har, oavsett om ni gjorde det under corona, körde ni hela den här internetserien?
Bara en sån grej?
Ja precis, jo men vi säger, som serien, anledningen till att vi har den kontinuiteten, givetvis nu har vi anordnat många tävlingar och vi får ju rutin på det och liksom det är så mycket annat blir ju ett hantverk och ja man får vara klurig, jag har sett ju de flesta tävlingarna till exempel med grenar och vikter och sådana saker.
Man måste ju hela tiden ha i bakhuvudet, vi är minimal styrka med funktionärer på våra tävlingar.
De som är våra funktionärer tävlar ju själva.
Fast kanske inte just i den tävlingen de är med och är funktionärer i men liksom det måste funka och man kan inte slita ut folk.
Det ska inte vara som när jag var funktionär 2016 att jag ska gå och bära tillbaka allting och lyfta upp allting åt atleterna liksom utan det måste funka smidigt liksom.
Då gäller det att lägga in den energin inför när man planerar grenarna och tävlingarna liksom.
Då kan man jobba bort mycket sådant så det blir lättrådda och det blir enkelt att arrangera.
Sen finns det vissa grenar där du inte kommer ifrån där det är liksom mycket slit och så här men har man lite huvud med sig och planera det innan och där tror jag vår styrka är lite och det är därför vi kan ha så många tävlingar också.
Jag menar när vi har en del tävlingshelg i Regnhult så har vi liksom tre tävlingar på två dagar.
Vi har två på lördagen och sen en på söndagen.
Sen så river vi ihop allting och ställer i ordning och så liksom åker vi hem eller så.
Så det gäller att ha ett tempo på det.
Det tror jag vi är bra på.
Kan du ge mig någon sorts känsla för hur många som tränar strongmen idag och hur många som tävlar i strongmen och kanske även vad ratioen är mellan män och kvinnor i den här sporten och lite hur det funkar.
Har du någon känsla för det?
Jag kollade nu hur många vi har anmälda till serien kommande säsong nu.
Vi släppte ju deltävlingspaketen här ganska nyligen.
Då är vi uppe i 86 i våran serie då.
Då har vi inte fyllt elitklassen och vi har inte fyllt omklassen än även om det är på god väg.
Så jag menar, i våran serie så håller vi igång i alla fall 100 personer.
Det är ju liksom, jag skulle nog tro som aktivt tävlar i sporten.
Nu skjuter man ju från höften ordentligt.
Jag skulle nog kunna tänka mig att det är runt 200 personer som kanske tävlar.
På amatör-
och elitnivå.
Men vi märkte ju det när vi startade vår dam-serie nu i år, att det har verkligen gett ringar på vattnet.
Dam-sidan tror jag är den klassen eller det som kan utvecklas allra mest.
För om du tar Crossfit till exempel, det är ju tekniskt väldigt svårt.
Jag som står utifrån tycker att det är det.
Gå på händer, göra toast to bar och sådana saker.
Medan strongwoman och strongman är ju enklare.
Du ska lyfta upp en sak och gå med den bort dit.
Det kan man mäta med vikt och allting sånt.
Sen ska man nog inte sticka under stolen med.
Det har vi märkt på dam-sidan nu, att det är så jäkla häftigt att se när de första gångerna de kommer och testar det.
Vi har ju haft mycket såhär att folk ska komma och prova på.
Då tror de inte att de ska klara saker och ting, men fasen, den känslan när du känner dig stark, det får du göra i strongman och strongwoman.
Det är det jag tror är viktigt.
Får man igång dam-sidan ordentligt så fan, det finns bra förutsättningar där till att få in ännu mer utövare.
Just att få folk att ta sidor på från styrkelyft, crossfit och testa sporten.
Har du väl testat en gång, så de flesta blir förvånade över hur kul det är.
Så är det.
Det kan man inte sticka under stolen med.
Någon tjej Frida från Jämla, hon har ju testat och tävlar på hög nivå i styrkelyft.
Hon tyckte ju att silverrygge när hon var med där, det var bland det roligaste utanför styrkelyft som hon har gjort.
Så kan man få folk att ta sidor och spår.
Där tror jag att det finns stora möjligheter.
Men som sagt, jag skulle nog tippa på kanske 200 som tävlar relativt regelbundet.
Kanske mer, men vi har ju en stor del av de 200 vi har i vår serie i alla fall.
Tror du att det överhuvudtaget någonsin kommer finnas en möjlighet att ha en betald serie?
Vad hade kräfts för att Strongman ska bli kommersiellt?
Det har ju börjat komma en del influencers, eller vad vi ska kalla dem.
Säg till exempel unga tjejer, det finns ju en Cassandra som är fruktansvärt stark.
Jag vet inte, hon Maria Ting bara flörtade lite med Strongman-världen.
Hon har ju tävlat i perioder, hon har varit lite på våra tävlingar med.
Du har ju Tofan till exempel, han, Turbo-Burken, det är ju också en ung kille som har varit på våra tävlingar.
Han är väl 18 eller något.
Ja, precis.
Men det finns ju några unga menar jag som håller på så det sprider ju lite, och sen vet man ju att Crossfit har flörtat mycket med Strongman, de har ju lagt in många sådana moment och sånt där, men Strongman i sin rena form, det som ni sysslar med kanske är ju fortfarande en väldigt liten sport.
Ja, ja.
Vad tror du hade krävts för att man skulle få en riktig kommersiell serie det där i Sverige?
Ja, det är svårt att säga.
För det första tror jag egentligen att det krävs att man, att i så fall om det ska bli det, att det krävs mer utövare, eller så.
Och sen är det ju liksom, om vi nu, du sa det här med flötten med crossfit, och det är om man tar Rogue till exempel som är väldigt stora och har startat och kör i renodlade strongman-tävlingar, de också, de har ju mycket kapital och de har ju vävt in strongman även i sina crossfit-tävlingar.
Mycket Famous Walk, Oko, säckbärning och sådana saker som vi har vanligt förekommande i våra tävlingar.
Det är nog kanske lite att det kom in en stor aktör som ser möjligheterna med det.
Jag vet du och jag har ju diskuterat att det är ju kanske en kul spot att synas i, för det är ju lite spektakulärt att man lyfter en bil eller man välter stora traktor, däck och liksom det har man då som vi försöker ha i vissa av våra tävlingar.
Fotografer som är med och kan ta lite snygga bilder så blir det kanske liksom ett värde i det.
Som du har nämnt, det kanske är svårt att tjäna in pengarna på att sälja strongman utavsvin, med tanke på hur få vi är.
Det är ju inte så man kan sälja in det kanske, men jag tror ändå att det finns goda potentialer till att få det men det är nog inte lätt.
Sverige är ju ganska litet liksom och en kommersiell serie, ja vem vet, det kanske Jaskos serien är om några år.
Någon gång, någon gång.
Nej men liksom vi har ju sagt det att serien, den är ju inte, den har ju liksom inte någon fast form.
Nu har vi fått igång elitklassen hyfsat och vi har börjat med damklass och den rör sig hela tiden och vi ska dra ner i våra tyngsta klasser nu, de som tävlar lite mer med tyngre vikter eller så.
Där ska vi dra ner antalet del-
tävlingar till två om året istället.
För vi har sett att de pallar inte att tävla i den utsträckningen som de gör eftersom de kanske kör något kval på sommaren och tjejerna kör lite Sverigestarkaste kvinnor och så.
Vi såg ju bara våran seger när vi placerade upp det.
Och ska man se till helheten så fan får de inte haft så mycket tävlingar på damsidan till exempel och sen har de jättemycket att välja på.
Då blir det kanske lite för mycket för dem.
Så nu skalar vi ner det på de tyngsta klasserna till nästa år.
Jag tror det kan bli riktigt bra eller så.
Men vem vet.
Jag vet att ni har fått något förslag från någon att de tycker att vi ska byta namn på serien.
Men jag tycker ju liksom, jag gillar ju det här jazzgo-serien liksom.
Om man slår upp det i Wikipedia så är det liksom änga gäng och allt vad det står liksom att man spelar på fotboll på anläggningar utan riktiga arenor liksom och så där.
Det är lite där vi ska hålla till.
Men sen, om vi kan ha riktigt hög nivå på våra tävlingar så spelar ju inte det någon roll.
Är stråmmän en landets sport?
Förstår du vad jag menar då?
Är det folk från bygden som tävlar eller är det folk från Stockholm och Göteborg?
Om man tittar lite vad tävlingarna finns för någonstans, så ska vi inte bara räkna oss som finns nere i Småland.
Men jag tror ju liksom att det är folkligt, det är lite mer landsort, det tror jag absolut eller så.
Det är nog därför det inte kanske är så mycket tävlingar just i Stockholm och Göteborg.
Men det vore riktigt kul att kunna ändra på det för det tror jag också är en grej som gör att hade man kunnat få igång lite mer tävlingar på amatörnivå närmare huvudstaden och Göteborg då tror jag det hade kunnat locka fler.
För nu är det väldigt såhär, det är några killar uppe i Östersund som anordnar lite tävlingar och det är vi här nere, sen är det norra nere i Skåne som anordnar.
Och nu har ju killarna i Strength Results för att anordna lite tävlingar uppe i Molkå med.
Men annars är det liksom, det finns inte så mycket kring huvudstäderna.
Så jag skulle nog säga att det är en folklig spot, men det är marknad, träskor och...
Ja, bondagång, det hör man ju liksom.
Det är ju folkligt.
Jag fattar, jag fattar.
Om vi skulle fråga folk på gatan sådär om strongman, då vet de ju vem Magnus Samuelsson är typ.
Det är väl vad min mamma vet, kanske.
Men hur ser svensk strongman ut idag?
Finns det några som försörjer sig på det?
Eller finns det någon som lever som det, som elitidrottare?
Nej, det gör det nog inte.
Utan det finns de som har sponsorer och såhär.
Jag är dåligt insatt i hur det ser ut.
Men försörjer sig gör jag nog inga på det.
Det är nog mer så att vi har en sådan som till exempel Johan Espen Krona som kronamannen nere i Skåne.
Där han har tävlat flitigt och har haft egna sponsorer som har sponsrat hann när han är iväg och tävlar.
Så jag tror faktiskt inte det ser ut.
I nuläget finns någon som lever på det.
Jag vet faktiskt inte om Magnus Samuelsson gjorde det på sin tid, just när han var aktiv eller så.
Men han har ju byggt upp ett fantastiskt varumärke.
Han är ju fortfarande, i Svensons ögon så är han Sveriges starkaste man.
Exakt.
Nu är det liksom Fredrik Johansson.
Man försöker förklara att Strongman är en tävling som faktiskt, eller Sveriges starkaste man är en tävling som görs varje år.
Det har hänt en del sedan dess.
Men han har ju byggt upp ett fantastiskt varumärke.
Det kan man ju inte ta ifrån.
Och sen var han ju en duktig idrottsman när det begav sig med.
Kan du se något mönster bland dem?
Du har ju ändå anordnat en hel del tävlingar och sett eliten på nära håll.
Kan du se något mönster bland dem som blir riktigt, riktigt bra?
Vi har ju haft två killar som gjorde debut hos oss i våran amatörserie.
Jakob Larsson och David Ebbeke.
Och nu även Jesper Hansson.
De stack ut när de tävlade.
Man märkte liksom att det fanns ett driv hos dem.
Och nu har de ju varit där alla tre var.
Ja, David och Jakob tog ju sig till final 2022 och Jesper fick ju en plats nu i finalen i år.
Och Jakob Larsson tog sig till final i år.
Så det man kan se det är alltså det.
Man ser lite när det är någon som sticker ut absolut.
Hur menar du att man ser det?
Ja, men man märker det.
Om jag ska ta exemplet med att sticka ut, om vi tar till exempel David Ebbeke som jag nämnde.
2019 hade jag ett seminarium med Martin Forsmark där jag hade min träningsutrustning.
Jag tror vi var 35 personer på lagret.
Då var David där för första gången.
Han var snäll och följde med sin mamma.
För hon skulle få seminariet, Maria.
Och så bjöds det på smörgåståtar med.
Han gillade smörgåståtar så han hängde med på det.
Första gången han provade på det, det var under det seminariet, och då gick han med 150 kilo per hand i Farms Walk.
Jag tror han pressade en bra bit över 100 kilo över huvudet.
Han hade aldrig hållit i en stock innan.
Man såg att han...
Där finns det potential.
Han hade en bra stomme, en bra grund att stå på.
Jag tror det absolut kan sticka ut.
Sen finns det de, jag vet vissa som tror att bara för att du är stark i marklyft, så blir du en bra strongman.
Det lirar ju inte alltid med varannas.
Marklyft är en gren, och det finns ju flera grenar i strongman, så det är nog svårt att bli bra på allting.
Men man kan få någon känsla för vissa personer, absolut.
Det var samma sak med en kille som heter Victor Johansson, som tävlade i minus 90 förut.
Han gjorde sin första tävling i slaget om Småland 2017, och där fick man också, det andra var lite större än honom, och han var liksom 90 kilo, muskelös, och alla såg ju att han stack ut, de där andra stora killarna, men han hinner ju med ändå, trots att han är mindre, smalare och smättare.
Så absolut kan det synas.
Det är nog en känsla man får när man tittar på det.
Sen är det svårt att sätta fingret på vad det är som gör det, men absolut finns det de som sticker ut helt klart.
Upplever du att, vi kallar dem för vinnarna, de som är topp, topp, topp, upplever du att de har, är de mer aggressiva eller är de lugna i sin tävling?
Till exempel i kampsport är det ju, vissa är väldigt aggressiva i sitt sätt, och vissa är ju extremt avslappnade.
Jag tänker att det är samma i strongman, man går ju in i tävlingsmomentet med olika känslor.
Ja men så är det nog, det är nog väldigt individuellt.
Vissa går in i sig själva är lugna, och andra är mer hetlevade och taggat till ordentligt och såhär.
Det ser inget mönster i vilka som vinner.
Nej, det är nog väldigt individuellt faktiskt, så det tror jag.
Säg att man vill komma in i strongman, dels vill man börja träna, vad ska man göra då?
Och dels vill man börja tävla, vad ska man göra då?
Ja, men vill man prova på spotten, så liksom, då finns det ju, på Facebook finns det en sida som heter Strongman i Sverige.
Jag vet faktiskt inte vem det är som har startat den sidan, jag undrar om inte det är killarna på Maxstyrka som har startat den eller någonting sånt där.
Jag tror att det är det, för att de har nog adminroll i alla fall.
Ja, det har jag också av någon anledning, jag vet inte om det är.
Men jag har inte startat den, men där finns det, där kan man hitta mycket information och man kan ställa frågor rakt ut i luften liksom om vad utrustning finns och sådär.
Det vet ju ni med att det börjar komma mer och mer Strongman-utrustning på gym.
Även på vanliga kärnor kan det finnas hapollon, axla, stockar och lite oko, lite väskor och sådana saker.
Så det går nog att hitta liksom och sen likadant många bygger ju själva med, men klart det är svårt om man vill testa det.
Men som sagt, om man skulle vilja prova på spotten så är mitt förslag att man ska ställa frågan i den gruppen eller höra av er till Kraftkamp så kan vi förmedla vad det finns gym och vad folk håller på för någonstans.
Så får man bra tips, eller tror jag.
Jag tycker folk är väldigt hjälpsamma.
Det är ofta folkfrågar, jag bor i den här orten, vad är närmaste gymmet?
Och så skriver folk det eller så säger de jag har det i mitt garage, kom dit och kör.
Jo men så är det.
Det är en väldigt öppen community.
Ja men det är det, helt klart.
Så det är mitt förslag, skriv i den gruppen Strongman i Sverige på Facebook eller så hör av dig till Kraftkamp.
Om du är nyfiken på att testa så ska vi försöka hjälpa dig så mycket vi kan.
Och om man vill börja tävla, vart börjar man som?
Du har varit på gymmet, du har testat att gå med något ok någon gång och några farmers, alltså du är på grund nivå, men du vill bara se vad det är liksom.
Hur börjar man tävla?
Ja, vi har ju tävlingar som sagt.
Vi har ju både jaskocen och silvryggen.
Men om vi säger jaskocen, det är inte så lätt.
Vi har ju det dilemmat nu, att det är många som vill tävla i våran serie, men vill bara köra en tävling.
Men vi försöker ju sälja hela konceptet med våran serie, så vi prioriterar ju att sälja deltävlingspaket där alla deltävlingarna ingår.
Så jag hade nog faktiskt samma sak där.
Kollat, slängt ut en fråga i Strongman i Sverige, om det är någon tävling på gång.
Det finns även en grupp på Facebook som heter Vi i folkklassen, där det är mer fokus på amatörtävlingar.
Släng ut en fråga där också.
Det finns många, det har blitt fler arrangörer till tävlingar nu, som jag nämnde killarna i Molcom, som kör strength results.
De kör ju tävlingar på amatörnivå, vi har några nere i södra Sverige, Strongfuls heter de, de kör lite tävlingar då och då.
Sen är det kanske inte många som har den framförhållning som vi har, där vi har spikat hela nästa år med våra serie eller så.
Så det är kanske svårt om man vill, jag vill tävla nu och så går man in och kollar i gruppen och så finns det inga tävlingar just nu kanske.
Men kolla i de grupperna, där hade jag nog, och sen är även Max Styrka har väl en tävlingskarriere för mig, när de lägger upp lite tävlingar och sånt som är på G.
Men för mig vet jag inte hur uppdaterade den är.
Nej jag vet inte heller.
Men det är samma sak där, undrar man liksom, skriv i grupperna, hör av er till oss, vi hjälper så många vi kan vidare.
Nu känner vi ju folk lite över hela Sverige, så oftast vet man ju om någon som har lite utrustning någonstans, och vet om någon som kan ha någon tävling någonstans också.
Vi kan väl också nämna att er i Norma är ganska lätt på er Instagramkonto kraftkamp.
Ja, där är vi frekventa.
Vi svarar så ofta vi kan.
Sen kan det ta lite, vi har ju våra dagliga jobb liksom, men eftermiddagar eller luncher och så där, så svarar vi alltid, det går fort.
Ja, jag tror att vi känner oss ganska klara där Kim.
Ja, jag har svamlat nu känner jag.
Jag är otroligt tacksam för att du ställde upp i podden.
Jag tror att det är väldigt intressant för de som är, dels finns det ju många som vill höra dig prata, erat community.
Dels finns det nog många som är lite nyfikna på Strongman-sporten och vill, man vill komma in men man är lite nervös, då kan det vara skönt att få en människa bakom som man vet att det är inte så farligt.
Är det någon som vill ha några frågor så jag säger det igen.
Tveka inte på att höra av er, vi svarar så snabbt vi kan.
Tack så mycket för att jag fick vara med på den.
Såklart, tack så mycket.